here for reaction author of the giant
awakens retired lieutenant colonel
Oliver North Colonel thanks for joining
us you know there are some people that
are concerned that you know 110 billion
dollars is that money well spent that
the president's assuring us that he's
going to deal with it responsibly but
110 billion dollars American people
aren't seeing that kind of money it's
coming out of their pockets
well it's coming out of all of our
pockets but it's money well spent I and
my humble opinion this is very much like
what Ronald Reagan did back in the 80s
and I do have some experience for that I
know that makes me a lot older than most
of our viewers but in fact he's he
believed in supporting Freedom Fighters
he did it in Latin America he did it in
Angola Guinea bissau Mozambique he did
it in Afghanistan those people were
willing as the Ukrainian people are to
use their blood and our bullets and by
the way most of that 110 billion total
between the 45 the 1.7 and the previous
65 over one point over 110 billion is
spent here in the United States it's
provided to contractors and defense
logisticians and the kinds of people who
build the kinds of systems that we're
getting so most of that money is spent
here in America good hard-working
Americans have the jobs and when you
look at that kind of an investment what
would be the difference if when the
giant does awake and that's all that's
all about communist China out a plug for
this book the idea of it is to make sure
that they get the right message and to
make sure that Putin gets the right
message no more invasions and that means
the people in Taiwan are going to need
the same kinds of weapon systems that
we're now providing to the ukrainians
and we better get hot at it because the
Communist Chinese aren't backing down
but they're watching very carefully what
we're doing and so Jason in my humble
opinion this is money well spent and
it's in its expensive stuff the Patriot
batteries themselves are are very
expensive when you look at each one of
the Patriot pac-3 missiles
literally we well comes in well over
excuse me a billion dollars a battery
and a million dollars a missile so
you're trying to shoot at stuff that's
being flown by Putin as he's trying to
redo redraw the boundaries of Europe a
patriot battery 1.5 billion each Patriot
missile 4 million the max range about a
hundred miles so the Iranians shock the
drones 80-pound Warhead 25k a piece
that's what we're up against and he's
got volleys and volleys of them that
they're firing at infrastructure in the
dead of winter
uh Colonel the concern is that Vladimir
Putin turns this suddenly into to World
War III and does the you're familiar
with Putin does this provoke him in such
a way that it gives him a justification
to escalate uh war and and Take It
Outside The bounds of of Ukraine
look at he's been rattling the nuclear
saber since all of this before all this
began on the 24th of February he's and
Putin does this routinely and my humble
opinion I don't think Vladimir Putin
could fire a nuclear weapon anywhere in
Europe I think there have been so many
mutinies in his Armed Forces there are
some people are just not going to push
the button they're not going to go to
the right place with that missile launch
system it's their their permissive
Action Link program is entirely
different than ours that weapon has to
be in the right place to be fired at a
very specific Target and there's Pilots
that aren't going to fly their weapons
the downside from from my opinion the
downside of the Patriot batteries is
they're only sending one the maximum
range for a patriot missile is about a
hundred miles okay and there's a minimum
range because you don't want it going
off right over your head and if Vladimir
Putin puts his Hypersonic weapons on a
on an aircraft that's over Russia are
they going to authorize the the law
launch of a patriot missile into Russia
I mean there's a whole bunch of things
that need to be worked out in this thing
not not only the training takes to make
sure that the folks can do it
sure and uncertain things
been there done that
yes well and we're at the discussion in
this country I wish we had more more of
a debate about it Lieutenant Colonel uh
Oliver North thank you for joining us
tonight on Hannity do appreciate it